in 2016 people magazine were right to
vote playing the sexiest man i've never
seen a bigger piece of but as a matter
of fact i should throw this water all
over the guy
that's not my style
whoa
this is like doing a ouija board or
something
be you what part of you is i think i can
agree this can get competitive quickly
yeah i'm leaving it right there
[Music]
pineapple on pizza is disgusting
what ah i don't understand why people
get so scared of pineapple on pizza
i've had pineapple with jalapeno on the
pizza okay and it's a great combination
come on it's amazing it's disgusting
no i've never in my life ordered a
pineapple pizza that's unnatural
pineapple mixed with ham or mixed with
bacon on pizzas
oh my god why don't you just give me a
bucket now so i can
what don't you like about it what do you
mean what do what i like about it uh
pineapple is a fruit it's called a
hawaiian oh oh i get it i see what's
happening oh god
no it's bad pineapple pizza is called
hawaiian pizza it was actually invented
in canada
yeah no i grew up in canada listen don't
blame the canadians
for your own strange tastes you know
i like it i would never normally order
it but if someone presented to me
pineapple pizza on set and i was hungry
so you strongly agree with it
i'll go here i'll go here yeah i was
like because you're acting like you just
i love loving i can't remember the last
time i had pineapple on pizza to be fair
i didn't know that you could mix
pineapple with cheese and enjoy it
that's disgusting okay well what do you
like on your pizza uh how about just
some cheese just cheese and little
tomato and some sauce that's it yes
that's it no i didn't want anything else
on it when you got freaky with your lady
well way back in the day did you not put
cheese on the nipples no no you told me
you did that's it
[Laughter]
i love pineapple but i don't like it on
my pizza tell you that next one before
we have a fight yeah
stealing movie set props is totally
normal three two one yeah uh you know
i'm into that come on yeah i'm just into
theft and jeff yeah me too it doesn't
happen here
doesn't matter if it's
who owns things you know that's like a
weird
human concept it's like oh this is mine
until it's mine
what kind of things have you stolen me
hearts
arts minds souls
moments
ideas baseball is more entertaining than
cricket
three two
one
yeah i mean
qriket is a okay baseball is baseball
cricket's much more enjoyable than them
is that the
baseball is more entertaining whoa
yes but i'm a huge dodgers fan so you
can doesn't make a difference it's not
as fun sport as qriket
american football is better than soccer
[Music]
yeah i disagree too
no i don't think i mean i like american
football i just will never understand
very dangerous why it's called football
because they don't use their feet i just
don't understand why it's called
football yeah it should be causally
different maybe throw ball
whatever you want to call it
don't kick
rugby is better than american football
three two well i'm biased i mean i
think this is really
this is where we break up yeah wait now
uh aussie rules rugby or no no no this
is like rugby union just look at the
traditional rugby i grew up with it i
didn't grow up with american football
you know and um well nobody's perfect no
that's right no one's worth it being too
short is better than being too tall
one
two
[Music]
yeah yeah
yeah
strongly agree does not appear a pants
or a shirt that i can't find in my size
i mean talking about talking about
anything women's sneakers if i like them
i'll just get a bigger size they're
available for me uh some some women's
pants i'm not afraid to admit it i've
been in them uh you know they just
they've just been a better fit for me i
got little hips you were in women's
pants well i mean we don't have to get
into it they weren't said it well it was
a pair of pants that could have been
quote unquote unisex they weren't
actually my stylist didn't tell me uh
she just put me in them and i was like
man these jeans are nice wow she was
like well they're they're a petite fit
first of all i'm confident with whatever
i do
i'm just saying it was a shock to know
that i was in a pair of women's how do
they feel though how do did they feel to
be honest with you dj made my ass feel
amazing uh like i told you my hips are
different so it's a different whatever
we don't need to get let's go to the
next let's go to the next one captain
america has the best suit of any
superhero doctor strange has the best
costume in the marvel universe i mean i
am a faker
i have to i mean look i'm obviously a
little biased but we we have to we have
to play
bye bye our truths
it's not the truth it's not the truth
it's the suit for him
and it works for him but if we're
measuring against all the avengers let's
be honest it's not the best
they're all better than mine it's a
good card good costume where i strongly
agree is how nice it is to wear compared
to a lot of other costumes which are not
so nice no i love his cape
the cape is special
yes cloak cloak club club sorry excuse
me
how's scarlet witches to wear it depends
on what position
i am i need to be in and where we're
constantly
in
harnesses yeah and that's a special
feeling
i'm glad i have a lucifer that's another
honestly this is where i get because for
me pragmatically it is far less
uncomfortable than what most people have
to go through flight would be the best
superpower to have
one
two
three i don't know i disagree
i disagree me too yeah what kind of
superpower would you like i want i want
to be able to hold my
i don't want to [ __ ] anymore
like hold it in yeah i don't want to be
able to anymore oh so just no more no it
comes out i'm not even holding it's just
no more no more but that's my power if i
chose to right i could but my power is
saying i don't want to today
i'll shut it off so if i will i can eat
all day right and on that day if i feel
like going i'll go but i'm like not
today
that's my power wow yeah
on command boom whoa come on yeah that's
it i want x-ray vision so i can see
through
oh
oh
[Music]
wait
[Music]
you know like when you look out you see
a sea of people yeah i see that
what are you trying to see specifically
just you
know just like they're inside people's
heart soul
american food is better than british
food
[Music]
i don't really i don't know i haven't
had enough of y'all's food
jaffa cakes you can't go wrong with a
drafter cake
wow that is really cool
would you like one sure
it's uh like an orange
no
i don't like orange flavor i think
try it though it's not orange flavored
it's actually got orange in it yeah
orange chocolate not for me
try try try try it
it's double tasty that does that don't
smell right
smell it smell it give it a moment give
it a smell
i can smell it because it's in my mouth
that doesn't smell very good
you haven't got to the orange bit yet
though oh that's going to be the worst
this is not my vibe
it's like if you can make something that
you don't want
make how i would make this
okay okay
okay it's not orange filling orange
jelly
[Music]
no absolutely
sure okay
the star wars universe is the best
cinematic universe
yeah
i i love it yeah me too i love it yeah
do you think you've got the most
dedicated fan base
it feels that way yeah yeah the star
trek spans might have something to say
about that
ignite a war yeah
people beating each other up in cinema
cues around the world
and marvel as well of course
yeah well
[Laughter]
i would trust tom holland with a spoiler
three two one
he does that a lot yes i'm beginning to
think now he just does it so that i can
be seen as a babysitter yes
just making wild noises putting my hands
over his yeah i put my hand over his
mouth and all sorts are there new
characters in this movie
no i didn't know that it's kind of fun
it brightens up the day it makes me look
like a saying or at least better at it
than he is and i'm not sure i am it
would be on my own
doing it intentionally i don't think so
anyway but um it's actually really
charming sweet you know yeah
the legs might bang your feet
um
just right there just leave it up to the
people yeah
it's not roasted
tell us
a spider best quality is a spot
sorry
that's qualities that i know
you have the annoying capability of
doing everything very well
thank you um
i don't know anybody ever saw everything
battle i'm still feeling the uh respect
for that she's still her he told me that
he was just gonna we were just gonna
keep it chill so i didn't see that i
couldn't make this i didn't come to play
i thought we were you know i thought we
were working together but it's whatever
he has this annoying capability of being
able to do everything really well so
it's like when you're when you're
watching him flip and then land and then
fight and then do all these things you
know you're you're great at it and you
do it with such ease
chairs
cheers
anglo-american relations
impression of me is pretty goddamn good
don't worry about us we just talking
that's it
i like american football i just don't
understand why it's called football
because they don't use their feet yeah
it should be causally different maybe
throw ball whatever you want to call it
but you don't
you do kick it yeah